[MUSIC PLAYING]
TROY TOMAN: Well,
welcome, everybody.
Thanks for coming
out to hear our talk.
Rajesh and I are going to
be sharing some experiences
with you.
I realized I'm
trying to condense
about 18 months
of migration work
and a lifetime of
monitoring experience
into about 40 minutes.
But bear with us as we
try to run through this.
And hopefully there'll be
some time for questions.
So just to kick it off,
my name is Troy Toman.
I run infrastructure
engineering at Planet.
Some of the coolest work
I've ever done and some
of the least interesting
work at Planet, which
I'll talk a little bit
more about the cool stuff
that we do.
But my background has been sort
of in infrastructure and clouds
for quite some time.
And as for Planet,
we are actually
imaging the earth
on a daily basis.
So our first
mission as a company
has been to be able to
capture the landmass
of the Earth every day, which
amounts to about a million
and a half 29 megapixel
images covering about 350
million square kilometers.
That's over six terabytes
of data every day
forever that we have to manage.
And the other
interesting thing is,
that most people want to look
at pictures of the earth that
don't have clouds.
So I have a really
different cloud problem
than you've heard about from
most of the people here.
But you know, we'll dive
into that a little bit
as we go through this.
RAJESH RAMAN: So hi, everyone.
My name is Rajesh.
I am the chief
architect at SignalFx.
I joined SignalFx a little
bit over five years ago now.
I joined as part of
the founding team.
And I've been over there
working mostly on our streaming
analytics engine,
which we'll get
to know a little bit
about going forward.
Prior to SignalFX, I was at
Facebook for about four years
working on cluster
management and monitoring
related projects.
And prior to Facebook, I was
at Google for several years,
again working on cluster
management type software.
So a little bit about
SignalFx, so SignalFx
is a monitoring and operational
intelligence solution.
We help people understand
their cloud environments.
We take data from these
cloud environments--
be they from infrastructure
or from application from other
services that you
might be using--
bring that data into
SignalFx and process it
at very, very low latency,
real time analytics
and anomaly
detection, for people
to really get
insight into what's
happening in their system.
And we're very pleased to have
Planet as one of our customers
since 2017.
And we are very happy to
share the story that we're
going to have now with Troy.
So what we're going
to talk about today
is about Planet, primarily
all the cool problems
that they solve, all the
infrastructure that they use,
the problems that
they face in trying
to solve these complicated
image processing.
And how and when
they manage to do
their migration from their
legacy environment into GCP.
I'll chip in a little
bit about things
to think about when
you're planning
a migration such as this,
what kind of monitoring
and observability you
need to have in place
to have a successful migration.
And then to continue to operate
your environments successfully
post migration.
So Troy, you want
to take it away?
TROY TOMAN: So just to give you
some context, as I mentioned
before, our initial
mission in the world
was to try to capture
the Earth every day
and make that accessible
to as many people
as we possibly could.
And we're now kind of
moving-- we've accomplished
that first mission, we're
getting the daily imagery
of the planet.
But now we're kind of
moving up the stack
and realizing that
what people want
is actually data and
information, not just pictures.
And so they don't actually
want a picture of every spot
on the Earth every day.
They want to know, where there
are buildings, where there
are roads, when
things are changing,
when disasters have struck.
And so increasingly,
we're starting
to build an analytics layer
on top of our data engine,
and feeding that
into our customers.
So our platform, or the stack--
when we talk about full
stack, it goes all the way
from embedded computers
that are flying
500 kilometers above the earth.
So we build and run our
own ground stations.
We obviously have to
store, and manage,
and process tens of terabytes
of data every single day.
And then that all feeds back
through our user system.
We do that mostly on
the Google Cloud today.
It starts out with about
150 operational satellites,
the largest operational
constellation in the world.
We have, I think, over a
dozen, maybe close to 20 ground
stations around the world
that receive the data.
We upload that into the cloud.
We have tens of thousands of
VMs that sit in Google Cloud
that crunch on that data.
And then an API,
and sort of series
of ways for people to
access that information.
To kind of dive down
a little bit more,
from a software
perspective, this data
comes into our
processing engine.
So this is all the stuff that
kind of happens now in GCP.
But you'll hear me talk a little
bit about our data pipeline,
which is where we started.
And that really is about
getting our imagery
and doing all the work
that has to be done to make
that usable by customers.
For example, when you take
an image of the earth,
you've got a 2D image of what's
fundamentally a 3D surface.
And we have to take and
essentially map every pixel
that we take from space onto a
physical location on the earth,
because we want accuracy
within three meters.
So we have to know first--
you can have a slightly off
telemetry in space
that can cause
you to be 50 to 100 miles
off of where you thought
you were of the earth.
So there's a whole
set of processing
that has to go to make that
useful to our customers.
And then it turns out everybody
wants it in a different format.
People want web tiles, people
want analytic products,
people want
beautiful images that
look good that are
maybe stitched together,
mosaics of lots of
different images together.
And so all that sort
of number crunching
goes on in the background
of our platform.
So we do this.
You know, I think
we have somewhere
between 50 and 100
software engineers
spread around the company.
And we're located-- our
headquarters is here
in San Francisco.
We have a large office
in Mountain View.
But we also have offices
in Canada, Texas, Berlin,
and remote employees
sort of spread worldwide.
So it's a very
distributed environment.
Our development work is mostly
in Python, historically.
We are doing a lot more
with Go, with new pieces.
And then a lot of our front
end work is JavaScript based.
We are entirely cloud based.
We have almost no
on prem hardware.
And what I'm going
to talk to you
about is, a lot of our
stuff started in AWS.
We still have some things there.
Some things will
always remain there
because of regulatory
requirements
that we need Gov Cloud.
But we-- about 18
months ago, began
a process of
migrating to Google.
And I'm just going to tell you
a little bit of the things we
learned during that process.
So a timeline, you
know, I realized
we already have one
inconsistency in our slides.
We sort of talked about
integrating with SignalFx
in 2016, and you said 2017.
But we've been with
SignalFx, sort of embedded
in our infrastructure
very early.
And the big thing for us is,
really this marking point
of launching our 80 satellites,
our first production
set of satellites
in January of 2017.
And we knew that we
needed our cloud--
our cloud choice was going
to become kind of permanent
around that time frame.
Because once we started
actually downloading
a million and a
half pictures a day,
we were going to move a lot.
And as it was, we had
a lot of data to move.
So we began our evaluation
process around here.
We started our first phase
migration in December.
And then, actually, flipped live
before the last Next Conference
in San Francisco, which was
actually in March of 2017.
And then we've kind
of kept our phase two
migration going over the last
18 months or so since then.
And I'll walk you through
some of our experiences,
but this gives you a
general idea of the flow.
So why did we end up on Google
after we did our analysis?
There were a couple
of different things.
First of all, we really felt
there was a good product fit.
A lot of the network and
storage capacity pieces
lined up with a lot of the
data requirements that we had.
We particularly liked the
ability to use predictable VMs,
or preemptible VMs, which
have predictable pricing.
Versus things like
spot markets on AWS,
where the market fluctuations
were difficult for us
to manage.
The pricing model felt
very natural for how where
we came from this bursty--
you know, images sort
of flow in and out,
we're bursting up and down,
and it flowed well for that.
And we also have--
there are a lot of-- if you've
been around the conference,
there have been other geospatial
data providers talking.
But there's a community of
geopatial data providers.
There's a lot of new geospatial
features coming out in BigQuery
and other platforms.
And it just felt like a
good fit from a market fit.
We also, interestingly
enough, acquired Terra Bella,
which was the T in the alphabet
product line of Google.
Their satellite business is
actually a part of Planet now.
And so we have other
strategic relationships
that have made sense for us.
And we also, I
guess the last thing
I would say is, their commitment
to open source technologies,
particularly in Kubernetes
and some other things, lined
up well with how we wanted to
grow and do things at Planet.
So we did a two phase
migration at Planet.
Because all of those
satellites were going up
and we were going to
start getting rained down
with sat dat in 20--
last year, we made a
decision to get that moved
as quickly as possible.
I was looking at
one of the slides
beforehand, where it was
talking about Evernote
moving 3.5 petabytes of data
over a seven day period.
We moved 7 and 1/2
petabytes in under 30 days,
which I'll talk a little bit
about some learnings from that.
But that was a big
chunk of the move.
But we also ended up
moving about 40,000 servers
worth of work from one cloud
to the other in that same sort
of 70 to 90 day window.
And so I'll talk a little
about the things we learned
and where we end up.
We took the rest of our--
we had a lot of
merging applications
that were more customer facing
and less heavily trafficked.
And we actually did some
work to kind of refactor
those, moved them into
containers and Kubernetes,
and migrate them
to Google later.
Some things worked about that,
some things not quite so good.
And I'll talk about some
of the trade-offs there.
But that process is
actually still ongoing,
and has kind of dragged
out as we needed it to
over the course of the
last period of time.
So in that first--
you know, if you look at
our overall environment
today, some key tools that we
use for automation and tooling,
we tie into GitHub and GitLab.
We use their
automation environment.
We're heavily bet on
containers as a mechanism
for deploying apps.
Jenkins and Ansible, probably
other two heavy automation
tools.
Then we have our pipeline.
We're not very imaginative
at naming things.
So we have a company
named Planet,
we have an application
named Storage,
we have another
application named Jobs.
And I'll talk about those.
And then we kind of have
our API Services platform
that's Kubernetes based, that
has moved over since then.
So I talked about a
few of these pieces.
But I think, you
know, what I want
to say is, that the automation
that we had invested in
made the migration much easier.
And we intentionally decided
not to change a lot of that
when we moved to Google.
So obviously we had
to do some things
where we had to take
Ansible abstractions for AWS
and substitute them with
Ansible extractions for Google.
We had to go do a few
even commits to upstream.
You know, I think I
did a commit to Packer
to support some advanced
Google Cloud features,
because we are crazy people
that like to use stuff
in alpha and Google Cloud.
I'll tell a story
about that later.
But those open source
tools were there
and we leveraged them heavily
to move forward on the platform
as we went.
And it really served as a
pretty strong foundation
for making the migration
go relatively quickly.
So the phase one piece was the
storage and imagery platform.
And so we moved storage over.
It consists largely
of all the imagery
stored in GCS, just as images.
We don't do any special sort
of database for those images.
We store the blobs in GCS.
The sort of, secret
sauce I guess,
comes into play with how
we manage all the metadata.
So we keep track
of which satellite
it came from, where we took
the picture, what rectification
coefficients we need,
what color curves
we've applied to the image,
all that type of data
over the history of
the lifetime we keep.
And that used to be stored
in a Postgres database,
primarily because
of PostGIS, which
is the geospatial information
extensions to Postgres.
And so we moved a 20 terabyte--
I think a 10 or 20 terabyte--
Postgres database
over in the process.
Since we've been
on Google, that we
then migrated a lot of that
metadata out of Postgres
into a Bigtable.
But we did that as
a two step process
that worked very well for
us, and I'll talk about that.
Our jobs platform, really, is
just a batch queuing platform
that manages a pool of VMs.
And I'll give you an idea
of what that pool looks like
and how we scale that over time.
And then phase
two, which is what
we're in the middle
of now, is really
all of our container
based services.
So we moved all of
these public facing APIs
into containers,
onto Kubernetes,
self-hosted Kubernetes on
AWS, and then what we've done
is built a similar
platform on Google,
and then allowed people
to basically repoint
their deployments from a
Kubernetes environmen in AWS
to a Kubernetes
environment in Google.
We also make heavy use of
Cloud SQL, mostly Postgres.
And well, we have a lot
of Elasticsearch in here.
But I don't want
to talk about that,
because anybody that
does operations probably
doesn't like to talk
about Elasticsearch.
I'll answer questions
if you want.
But we do have a couple of very
large Elasticsearch back ends
for all of this as well.
So with that in mind, of the
background of what we did,
I'm going to let Rajesh
talk a bit about some
of the monitoring
ideas that I think
we both have a philosophy
for, but he has way more
experience with.
RAJESH RAMAN: Thank you, Troy.
So I'd like to talk a
little bit about how
you go about monitoring
something as complicated
as migrating from one
environment to another.
But the first thing
I want to raise
is, that when you're
considering such a large change,
you should really think
strategically about monitoring.
So obviously making a
change in cloud environments
is a big change.
But if you think about
it over the lifecycle
of your entire service or
your entire product, you know,
that's only one of the
changes that your system
has to be able to handle.
You'll obviously
be making changes
to various kinds
of implementations,
various kinds of
architectures, new builds, even
things like
configuration changes.
And these are all
things that you
will have to be
able to monitor over
the life cycle of your service.
Monitoring is not only about
observing system behavior,
but also understanding it.
You really want to have
insight into what's
happening inside your
service, not just seeing
that it's, OK, it's processing
some number of transactions,
but what's it doing
under the covers?
So that you know if
something goes wrong,
what's actually
happening under the hood.
And so when you're doing
something as complicated
as migrating from one
environment to another,
you want to ensure that you have
the right monitoring strategy
way before you actually
start doing the migration.
So you saw that Planet
actually started
using SignalFX a couple of
years before they actually
finished their migration.
And the reason you
want to do this
is, you want to
move as few things,
you want to change as
few things as possible
when you actually
do this migration.
You want to establish
all the baselines
and have all the observability
that you need way before you
actually execute the migration.
And it's a good opportunity to
use your upcoming GCP migration
as a forcing function to
ensure that you're putting all
the right monitoring best
practices in your organization,
the right philosophy
or observability,
and having the right tooling
and the right products in place
for you to ensure that
you understand what
your system is actually doing.
So the first class,
observability,
once you have it,
is not only going
to help you manage
this migration,
but it'll help you operate
your service after you
complete the migration.
So a few lessons to share
about monitoring in general.
So there's much
more to monitoring
than just infrastructure,
especially when you're
moving from one cloud
system to another.
So for one thing, like system
metrics are not very useful.
They are often not
even comparable across
different cloud environments.
Because for example, what's
an instance type in AWS
might not map exactly
to what you have in GCP.
And so it doesn't
really make sense
to compare things that
aren't really comparable.
It's like apples and oranges.
But there are some more
systematic problems
with using just system metrics.
So often times,
system metrics do not
indicate application
performance issues.
You know, your load
averages might look fine.
Your memory utilization
might look fine.
But your application
might actually
be struggling for
various other reasons.
And even when system metrics
do indicate system performance
issues, they often are not
very actionable in the sense,
they don't tell you what the
problem is, they just tell you
that there is a problem.
So you really need to go
beyond system metrics.
You want to take-- what we
call-- a data driven approach
to development and operations.
The key insight here is
that you cannot understand,
you cannot improve, you cannot
manage what you don't measure.
So you really need to think
about measuring all the things
that matter to you
as a person who's
developing an application.
What do you characterize
as the proper behavior
of that application?
Even if you have a really
simple service, for example,
it might be some kind
of a look-up service,
you get a request to
look up something,
you look it up in the cache,
if it's there in the cache
you can return it.
If it's not in the cache,
you put it into a queue,
and maybe there's a third pool
that pulls stuff off the queue,
looks it up in the database,
and then returns it.
Well, you should be measuring,
not only the number of request
that you're getting,
but you should
be measuring the number of
cache hits, the number of cache
misses, what's the size
of your queue, what's
the size of your
thread pool, what's
the utilization on
this thread pool?
Each of these
instrumentation points
is hardly like one
or two lines of code.
But believe me, it'll
pay off in spades
when something falls in the pot.
So if you're in
doubt, instrument, OK?
So the wrong time to wish
you had instrumentation
is when you're in the
middle of an outage,
it's 3:00 AM in the
morning, and you
wish that you knew what was
actually happening over there.
You see that things
are running slow,
but you don't know if it's the
database, or if it's the cache,
or what is the
problem right there.
So a fairly moderately
instrumented application,
you know, of
moderate complexity,
it's not unusual for
them to even send
thousands of metrics per host.
It's not unusual.
But once you do
that, if you have,
let's say, 1,000
metrics coming per host
and you have thousands or tens
of thousands of instances,
you are now looking at
millions of time series.
And you can't really absorb
that kind of information.
So you really need to use,
then, analytics to boil
all this information down
into a small number of KPIs
that you can actually absorb.
So obviously, you
need to be measuring
the KPIs, which are what
you promise as a service
to your clients.
So these are the SLAs, the
SLOs, the SLIs that clients
of your service care about.
You obviously need
to be measuring that,
because otherwise you cannot
guarantee that you're actually
meeting any of those objectives.
But equally, you should
also be measuring the things
that you, as an application
writer, care about, right?
you should be-- for example,
if it was that look-up service,
I would want to
know what the hit
ratio, what's the aggregate
hit ratio across the entirety?
Or what's the 99th
percentile of the queue sizes
across my entire tier?
What's the thread utilization
on my thread pools?
So there are some
small number of metrics
that will capture what's
happening in your system.
If you think about a pilot who's
flying a complicated airplane,
there's obviously a
lot of metrics that are
available to that pilot, right?
Everything from like various
hydraulic pressures, and oil
pressures, and oil temperatures,
and exhaust gas temperatures,
and all that stuff.
But that's not what's
on the pilot's HUD.
The pilot is
operating the system
based on a small number of
metrics that are projected
onto the head up display.
And yes, if something
happens, then
yes, they are available to you.
And those other metrics are
available to debug and fix
the problem.
And you need to take that
same sort of mentality
when you're operating
your own applications.
So use analytics to take all
this complicated information
and boil them down to a
small number of metrics
that you're actually monitoring.
Now second, use your
monitoring tools
to establish a baseline
for system behavior.
So this is one of
the reasons why
you want to set up your
monitoring and observability
tool-chain way before you
actually do the migration.
What is it normal
for your system?
It's not always a very
simple question to answer.
So here's a chart of activity in
one of SignalFx's own systems.
And you can see that it's
very strongly periodic.
This is activity over a week.
So you can see that
in the weekdays
there's a lot of
activity on the system.
During the weekends,
it's not so active.
And so, if somebody
came up to me and asked,
hey, Rajesh, is 30,000 normal?
Well, 30,000 is not normal
if it's Sunday afternoon.
It's also not normal
if it's Monday, noon.
But it is about normal if
it's Monday at 9:00 AM.
So what is normal would
depend a lot on your system.
So like, this system is,
of course, very dependent
on weekly behavior.
But you can imagine other
systems that we have--
for example, there
might be a warm up phase
when you push a service that
your caches all get cold,
and so it takes some time
for your caches to warm up.
And that might be
normal for your system.
There might be other things
where it's very periodic,
but on a monthly basis,
or on a quarterly basis,
or based on other
[? reasons of ?] activity that
might happen in your system.
So you want to make
sure that you're
capturing all these
metrics and you
have enough baseline
in them that when
you do your migration, you
have something to compare with.
If you don't have--
if you're not giving
yourself enough time
to establish that
baseline, you're
not going to be able
to, again, compare
and know that if your
[? migrated ?] instances are
kind of doing something
that is normal.
And of course, comparing
it to past behavior
is one notion of what's normal.
You might also want to compare
it to your other control group.
So if you're migrating
from let's say, AWS to GCP,
and you have some
instances running in GCP,
you want to measure apples
to apples comparison of what
is happening on GCP versus
what's happening on AWS.
And again, here, you don't want
to be doing the system metrics,
you want to be doing the KPIs
and the other metrics that
really give you a proper
comparison if your system is
working well.
Now this whole a
versus b is not just
like GCP versus AWS, right?
It can be, oh, here
it is my canary build,
or here's an alternate
implementation of an algorithm
which I think is going
to be much better.
But is it better?
You should be measuring it.
That's the only way you're
going to know if you actually
made an improvement or not.
And not just measuring it
in a synthetic benchmark.
You want to be testing
it in production
to make sure that it's working
as you intend it to work.
In this case, we actually
pushed out a canary build.
And you can see that
the canary build
is working very, very different
than the rest of the population
of the servers.
In this case, it was
actually an optimization,
so doing as it was intended.
If it was not, we
would have caught it
within a few seconds or minutes
and reverted the canary.
So the third thing is
that timeliness of metrics
and analytics is critical, OK?
So Micrososervices,
data sampling frequency,
there's a lot that can
happen within the span
of a few minutes.
Most of you are
familiar with all
these microservice architecture.
These are very large,
complicated dynamic systems.
They're growing and shrinking,
they're auto-provisioning,
they're auto-scaling, they
are doing a lot of stuff.
And a lot can happen within
a span of a few minutes.
So you may fail to identify
patterns and activity
by sampling, kind of like
coarse grained metrics,
or things that very,
very high latency.
Just imagine the [INAUDIBLE]
to continue, kind of
like the aviation metaphor.
Imagine a pilot trying
to fly an airplane where
all the instruments updated
once a minute instead
of every time they made
a change to the controls.
But that's what most people
are trying to do nowadays.
They are trying to
operate these very, very
large complicated systems
by looking at metrics that
operate like once a minute.
So low latency real time
monitoring really, really
lets you understand
how the system behaves
when you make changes to them
and you push a canary when
you update a configuration.
How does your
system really behave
to be able to identify
the patterns that happen
and to be able to react
very quickly when something
is happening that
you don't expect?
Or something that you don't
understand, or something
that should not be
happening, to be
able to identify those
behaviors and react to them,
remedy the problem, and verify
that your remediations are
actually working.
So, you know, the way I
like to think about it
is that your system is telling
a very complicated story.
And you should be watching the
movie and not a slide show.
So this is the value of real
time streaming analytics
in terms of having ingesting
higher resolution, low latency
data, and giving you analytic
insight instantaneously.
So to summarize, make sure that
you go beyond infrastructure
level metrics.
Measure all the things
that matter to your system.
And if you're in doubt, measure.
It's always easy to throw
data out if you don't need it.
But it's impossible to--
you can wish as
much as you want,
you're not going to get
the instrumentation in when
you need it when things
are falling apart.
Use analytics,
because at this point,
you're going to have
a whole lot of data.
You really need
analytics to help
you identify aggregate
system behavior,
identify outliers, deviations
from normal behavior,
and establish baselines
for system behavior,
and measure in real time.
Ingest at the highest
possible resolution
with the lowest
possible latency for you
to kind of operate your
system successfully.
So Troy is now going to talk
us through how Planet Labs did
their migration.
TROY TOMAN: So just to kind of
touch on some of the metrics
that we've used, first
of all, I apologize,
a lot of the migration we did
predated the year [? back. ?]
I can look in the
graphs that we have.
So most of the graphs are
not right during the middle
of the migration.
But I found some
that I think show
a lot of the kinds
of things that we
found during the migration.
And sort of how
we think about it.
So I'll dive into a few
of these more directly.
So this is kind of just to give
you an idea of the environment
that we were working in
during the migration period.
So this goes back
to July of 2017.
In December of 2016, we
started our migration.
We had everything
running on AWS.
We were processing about
300,000 images a day.
We had never run more than
20,000 of our workers VMs
in the history of the company.
And in fact, a couple
of years before that,
we hadn't run more
than about 500 of them.
So we had been on
this ramp for a while.
And in the middle
of this ramp, right
when we launched all of our big
satellites, we moved to Google.
And this is kind
of what happened
next, is we went really
quickly through this period.
So I talked about how we
launched a bunch of satellites
in January.
It actually takes us a
while to operationalize
those satellites.
So those satellites
didn't really
start coming online
until June and July.
But you'll see this big
shift in our workload
as we sort of went through
a whole set of things
around that period.
And then we've kept
going over time
as we launch more satellites
and got more products.
We actually hit a new record of
53,000 concurrent VMs running
just a few weeks ago.
And so this is just
kind of a good graph
to remind us where we've been
and what we've been up to,
and sort of the scale that we've
been able to get on the Google
Cloud.
Here's another example of where
we track API response time.
So this is a similar--
you know, this is an application
level metric, not really
system level metric.
But we're tracking just
response times and capabilities.
So this was actually a new
endpoint in our storage system
that we have been developing
for some new capabilities
that our developers
wanted to use.
And we're tracking it
sort of over history.
But you'll see that we can
tell when we flip the switch,
when that started
to go, you'll see
we found a problem somewhere
along the way where we got
huge spikes that we
cut pretty quickly,
and then were able to
correct and sort of monitor.
So just another example
of one of the small things
that we watch on our ops teams.
This one, I think,
is just a good way
of how you can watch
changes through the system.
And I do wish we could
sort of stretch this back
to the migration time frame.
But this is looking at some
metrics of our back end
database server for
that storage environment
that I talked about.
So this is an environment
that's tracking
over two billion objects
and all the metadata that's
associated with that.
So we moved it to Google and
learned some good lessons
about moving big databases
that I'll get to later.
But one of the big things
that we wanted to do
was actually leverage
Bigtable to manage
a lot of our metadata.
So we had all the stuff
stored in Postgres
in a horribly inefficient
manner, like just big JSON
blobs instead of
a Postgres column.
If you want to
have fun some time,
have 100K JSON blobs in Postgres
columns and try to manage that.
So we pulled all that data
out and put it into a Bigtable
and flipped the switch on
that in an environment.
And again, to track
sort of what we wanted,
our network
utilization the day we
flipped the Bigtable
switch just dropped.
Because all that data stopped
coming out of our system
and started coming out
a Bigtable instead.
So this was just like,
one of those metrics
that we could see what was
happening during that time
frame.
Another thing that
we did is we went--
we used to have an on disk based
backup where we would run PD
dump to get our backups--
PD based backup
to do our pieces.
But we switched over to actually
mounting an extra Persistent
Disk and snapshotting the
database to Persistent Disk
and then moving that
Persistent Disk.
And you'll see that new backup
popped in in our disk activity.
So this is actually the instance
where we do all of our backups.
And so we were getting
lots of disk activity
until we did the snapshot stuff,
and that sort of dropped off.
And then I guess, the last
thing that sort of shows here,
is we actually--
one of the things
about Postgres is
if you drop a
Bigtable or a column
in our case that was all this
JSON data, the storage for that
doesn't go away immediately.
You actually have
to dump and restore
the database to get it away.
So the performance came down
in the network bandwidth.
But that was all-- the
disk utilization was still
there in the system.
So we decided we would
build a brand new--
go from a [? 9.3 ?] server
to a [? 9.5 ?] server,
do a dump and import
of the database.
And as things sort of happened,
this was the first try.
It didn't work, which is kind
of why we see some spikes.
And then everything
goes back to normal.
But we figured out
why it didn't work.
And a few months later,
pulled the trigger again,
and sort of got to watch.
We'll see a new
database server, but we
were able to do a before
and after comparison
of the old to the
new to make sure
that the statistics lined
up and certainly didn't get
any worse than it did before.
So I think it just
sort of-- you know,
this is obviously over a
very long period of time.
So it's not what we
use operationally,
but it's great to
tell the story.
Or maybe this is our
version of the movie
of what happens to big
Postgres databases at Planet.
It is very useful for us.
Another big thing that we
get out of our environment
that we love is
the fact that we--
our AWS platform, our
monitoring and visibility
looks exactly like our GCP.
So I mentioned that we're moving
these Kubernetes environments
back and forth.
So we use an internal
tooling system called K2
to deploy Kubernetes into AWS.
And that K2 platform,
we name all of-- again,
we're really good at naming--
we name all of our clusters KK
something.
In Google, we move
to using Terraform
to deploy all of our stuff.
We actually got
kind of creative,
we call that tool Terraflop,
which is a little more
interesting than Terraform.
But it's all TFK.
So you'll see up here, we
get a common view of both--
and you know, our
Google cluster is
right next to our
AWS clusters as we're
sort of walking through
this environment.
And it goes even deeper.
This is an example of
our dashboard for one
of our clusters.
So this is a Google cluster.
These are the variety of metrics
that are our standard ops guys
use.
But this looks exactly the
same for our AWS clusters
as it does for our
Google clusters.
So if we get a page in the
middle of the night and-- we
don't get those, but
I hear people do--
when they wake up
at 3:00 AM, they're
not having to go like, oh,
which environment I am,
and what signals
am I looking for?
They see a lot of consistency.
I will say the one difference--
if I showed you the snapshot--
is, those two top lines
would be blank in AWS
because we've moved to a service
mesh [? linker ?] [? e-based ?]
ingress and we don't
have that in AWS.
But we've left the
format the same so
that the visibility to the
ops guys is also consistent.
So that is kind of an overview.
I thought what maybe
the most valuable thing,
rather than get into
the nitty gritty,
or at least maybe provide some
context for the nitty gritty,
is to share with you
some things that I think
we learned at Planet
about doing a migration
of this kind of scale.
Both about how to do them,
and maybe some things
about Google Cloud
in the process.
So my number one
recommendation to anybody
doing a migration like this
is, don't change anything
you don't have to change.
You know, well, so I'll
come back to that second.
So I guess, the
first thing actually,
before that, I sometimes
take this for granted
and I almost forgot we
put this in the slide.
But the planning part
is actually essential.
We were in a hurry.
But we took a lot of time
to evaluate the move,
make sure it was the right move.
Maybe more importantly,
we locked ourselves
into a conference
room in San Antonio
for like a week to think of all
the things that could go wrong,
and how we wanted to do this,
and have a lot of debates.
That time up front, even though
we felt a lot of pressure
to move fast was
invaluable in the process.
So don't shortchange yourself on
thinking about this stuff ahead
of time, and asking all
the crazy questions, which
will never be all the
questions you will find.
But you'll find that some of
those were really helpful.
The second thing,
and the one that
probably rings
the truest for me,
because we didn't
do this everywhere,
is change as few
things as possible.
It's super tempting-- and we
fell into this in a couple
of places--
but to want to fix
all the problems
of your service and your
app while you're migrating.
You know, I don't-- oh, I'm
in an old version of Ansible,
I don't get to use that anymore.
I want to get off a Postgres,
let's move to a Bigtable
while we move to Google.
Let's containerize
everything, we'll
go from Ansible base VMs and AWS
to containerized new solution
and GCP.
Resist that temptation.
It makes the migration
way more complicated.
And I guarantee you it will
take you three times longer
to move if you do
that than if you move
and then make the change.
So my recommendation
is to avoid that.
So we moved the biggest part
of our infrastructure, probably
75% of our servers and
applications in 90 days.
And the last 20% that
we're moving over
has taken us 18 months.
Because it's gotten
much more predictable,
people are changing
lots of things.
The refactoring that they want
to do before they move never
quite finishes.
And it just sort of
drags out, because it's
much harder to bracket, I
think, things around that.
And that worked for us.
Like, I think in
particular, had we
tried to take our 20
terabyte Postgres database
and migrate to Bigtable
while we're going to GCP,
the problem is more
things are going to break
and it's more
confusing what broke.
Did it break because Bigtable
didn't work for application?
Did it break because the
Google Cloud is different?
Did it break because
our VPNs didn't work?
Like, all of those things
just get more complicated.
So I think in some
ways, it's kind
of the antithesis
of a micro services,
or maybe a CI sort of
incremental change approach.
The more you [? bake ?] into
the change, the more complicated
it's going to be, the more
likely you're going to fail.
And it's actually going
to take you more time.
Another big thing, you heard
me sort of talk about this,
and I'll get some details.
But data gravity is real.
It seems-- like if you're
looking at migrating,
particularly from
something like AWS to GCP--
it seems like the two most
similar things on the planet
are S3 and GCS.
So you want-- it's
easy to just kind of go
like, oh, l got a
bunch of data in S3,
I'm just going to
copy that data to GCS.
The problem is, when
you start doing things--
and not everybody does
this on this scale--
but when you start talking about
moving seven petabytes of data,
it turns out there's
not an O'Reilly
book that is very
good about how to move
seven petabytes of data.
So we started by
doing some tests.
I took a database
that was on AWS
and I did a base backup to GCP.
And I was totally blown away
by how fast the backup was
and thought, wow, this
whole data copying thing
is going to be easy.
The problem is, one database
backup doesn't simulate
moving two billion objects from
GCS that was on in one bucket,
I would say.
And I can talk to you
about why that is.
But we have bucket with
multi-billions of objects
that we were trying
to move over.
And so we did this testing.
We thought the pipes are
big, because it turns out,
you know, the
advertisers and the ads
are all sort of go in
between those two networks.
Both Amazon and Google
are set up to do that.
But, you know, it
turns out we used the--
there's a cloud migration
tool that Google has,
that's actually quite good.
So we just like, we flipped that
on, we put it at the bucket,
we started running our
tests, and we're like, wow,
we're going to be here for
six months if this happens.
And so we sat down
with the Google team,
and we figured out that--
you know, part of it is
they're sort of serially
going through our
keyspace object by object,
doing these look-ups,
moving this data over.
And so what we ended
up doing to make
a long story a
little bit shorter,
is that we worked with Google.
And how our thing was
set up and we ended up
running 32 separate simultaneous
migration jobs by dividing up
the keyspace.
We had a pretty
distributed keyspace.
We use MD5 sums of
all of our images
to be the main storing place.
So it's wildly spread.
And we literally just took
that keyspace set, divided it
into 32 groups, and then
put those key spaces
into 32 separate migration
jobs and flipped the switch.
And 21 days later, 7 and 1/2
petabytes of data was moved.
So you can do it.
But you have to know
that it's probably--
like what we did doesn't
work for everybody else.
There's different
ways to approach it.
I would also say, probably
the other interesting story
that we had to move over
was the post-crash database.
So we have a self--
we have a series
of RDS databases,
but we also had these
larger databases
that were self-manage
Postgres instances.
And we thought the
simple thing to de--
simple thing to
do-- would just be
able to create a read-only
replica of our Postgres
database in Google.
So we tried to do that.
And one of the problems
that we ran into
was that we did
everything inside a plan
on private networks.
We have regulatory
requirements and other sort
of security things that keeps
everything without a public IP.
So our databases in
AWS had no public IP.
So it was basically
a VPN connected.
And we just couldn't get
latency throughput to keep up
with our database performance to
create a replica in GCP running
across VPNs.
What we ended up doing that
actually worked quite well,
was we took an Elastic
IP in AWS, assigned it
to the database that we
had, and ran a replication
across the public network
for the two or three weeks
where we were
replicating into GCP.
And it turns out
the public network
latencies were as
constrained as VPNs.
We actually got that to work.
And so we were running
for a long time
with a replica in GCP off of
our primary database in AWS.
The thing that we missed was,
we got so comfortable with that.
And I was going to
embarrass the guy
on the team who was
here, because he
was going to show up.
But he must have known that I
was going to talk about him.
Anyway, he got sick,
our main DBA got sick.
We all took our eyes-- we
actually had a graph that
showed our replication stats--
we took our eye off the ball.
We basically got
everything moved over
and ready to flip the
switch from that being the--
[? replicator ?]
being the primary.
And we had had some network
latency over the weekend
before we did it that caused our
other one to get out of sync.
And we ended up having
to wait two extra days
while the database
caught back up,
and we sort of got that
solved and flipped the switch.
So we kind of did part of
the migration on a Friday,
figured out it was going to
work, came back in Monday
morning, the replica
had caught up,
we flipped it, and went
the rest of the way.
Which was good, because Will
was on stage at Next the Tuesday
after that.
But we got it all done on time.
So I just think the whole
data thing actually turned out
to be quite hard.
We think about
things like Bigtable
and these systems that
are very different.
But actually it's
the things that
look the same that aren't
quite the same that
are the most complicated
parts about a move like this.
So for us, I think if
you're coming from an AWS
to Google environment, the
biggest challenges for us
were to understand networking.
You know, you kind of think
networking is networking,
TCP is TCP.
But I will say this is an area
where the two environments are
probably the most different.
And I don't even--
well, I don't know.
My team will pick one
that's better or worse.
I don't even that it's better or
worse, they're just different.
And it's helpful to know
what some of those are.
Probably the biggest
thing for us-- and this
is getting better.
I mean, I talked a little bit
about the need for the VPNs,
just how to set those up.
Like, VPNs are set up different
in AWS than they are in GCP.
Once you've figured out how
to pair them and set them up,
they work very well.
We still do a lot
of back and forth.
We have a huge amount
of traffic going
between the two clouds over VPN,
and that's worked well for us.
Google's use of SDN is
really powerful and extremely
performant, but causes some
things you just don't quite
expect sometimes.
For us, it had to do
with things like--
first of all, the internal
load balancer at Google
is actually not a load
balancer like you think of it.
It's not like an HAProxy or some
kind of load balancer instance
that looks like a device.
It's actually forwarding
rules in the network
that just moves traffic around.
So they call it a load
balancer, but it's really
a combination of front end
and back end forwarding rules
in the network.
That means you can't do things
like terminate SSL at the load
balancer internally.
Because it's really just
moving traffic to your back
end devices.
All of which works fine,
it's just different.
And that was hard for
us to get used to.
Some of the internal shared--
it's called shared
VPC, I keep wanting
to call it XPN. [? A ?]
few Google's were probably
remembered as XPN
before it became public.
But the shared VPC XPN stuff
was really early for us.
It's still kind of early.
Like, we didn't know
early on that you couldn't
expect to have the internal load
balancer not work across a VPN.
Because it's just a
device, networking device,
it should be available anywhere.
But when you dig in, you
understand why that is.
And we found ways to
sort of work around that.
And that all works
very well for us.
I think, also, private
DNS was a thing that
was missing when we moved.
It is being tested now.
We're actively
testing and hoping
to move to private zone
resolution inside of Google.
And so all these things,
I think, work fine.
They're just different.
And you need to be
aware of them as you're
sort of thinking through how
you're going to do things.
So I guess in
summary, for us, look,
our migration went really well.
We're running a massive
amount of stuff in Google,
it's going great.
We're moving new
stuff over every day.
We're going to
maintain a two cloud--
actually, I guess technically
we have some stuff.
And Azure will be in AWS for
our regulatory environment
that has to be in Gov Cloud.
But we're also digging in a lot.
I mentioned heavy use of
Bigtable, Cloud Memory Store.
A lot of the new services
that are coming out,
we're trying to migrate
and sort of [? embed ?] to,
even as we grow.
We are focused a lot on
Kubernetes and service mesh
approaches.
I will say that, partly because
of this private networking
mismatch, partly because
of some experience
we have in running
Kubernetes, we
run self-hosted
Kubernetes in Google.
We continue to evaluate
GK as an option.
But we actually have our
own Kubernetes deployment
that we run and manage.
And that has worked well for us.
And actually, we can piggyback
on a lot of GKE capabilities
that have been put into
the public use for us
to do things like
access underlying
IM roles, inner instances, and
credentialing and so forth.
A lot of work with the
move towards analytics
to incorporate GPUs and TPUs
into our infrastructure,
both in the Kubernetes
side and in other places.
And then there's just this
constant effort on our part
to balance cost and speed, take
advantage of preemptible VMs,
understand what the
best patterns are
for distributing our imagery,
and managing egress costs.
And so that's what keeps
us busy going forward
now that we've survived that
the basis of the migration.
And we're really sort
of excited about that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]